et on a des infos sur laura et laeticia
hallyday il paraît que ça commence à se
rabibocher
on a fait une récapitulative regardez
c'est parti si laeticia est de retour en
france pour assurer la promotion de
l'album posthume de johnny il se
pourrait bien qu'elle soit aussi de
passage pour enterrer une bonne fois
pour toutes la hache de guerre avec
david et laura de nombreuses sources
indiquent qu'entre les enfants du
chanteur et sa dernière femme les
relations s'améliorent une négociation
seraient même en cours pour mettre fin
au procès qui depuis l'an dernier divise
la famille alors que david demande les
droits sur 24 des 51 album de son père
laura quand elle souhaiterait la maison
de marnes-la-coquette ainsi qu'un
pourcentage sur les ventes des albums de
johnny et des objets intimes lui ayant
appartenu des demandes que laetitia
serait prête à accepter bref la
discussion semble bien engagée et les
relations entre laura et sa belle mère
serait meilleur que jamais alors
espérons que les négociations se passent
bien pour qu'on puisse enfin reparler de
johnny pour sa musique
l'avocat vous avez eu donc l'avocat d'un
des avocats sont en train de se
réconcilier apparemment quand il ya
juste un problème c'est qu'il faut être
tous d'accord il faut que david aussi
soient d'accord
david la seule chose qu'ils qui
l'intéresse c'est la question morale
d'accord après il ya un héritage changer
l'argent ils sont de l'argent c'est
moins bon temps pour lui ça si tant
qu'ils sont pas les trois d'accord il
pourra pas y avoir de consensus mais
c'est visiblement ils sont d'accord sur
plein de choses et il est fort probable
que ça s'arrange pour une raison bien
simple c'est que pour l'instant en
france tout est bloqué ça qu'il n'y a
pas d'argent
l'helléniste ne rapporte rien déficit un
peu ya procès ces dix ans sans une royal
qui donc a mon avis ça devrait aller
jean michel et lequel fantastique
hypocrisie quand même au départ laura
j'ai rien contre elle évidemment
personnellement mais nous faisait croire
que c'était seulement une question de
principe une question de qu'elle voulait
avoir un droit de regard sur l'héritage
artistique de johnny qui lui manquait
une petite pochette avec la signature de
son père sur l'album laura et serra
s'est tous mis que ce n'est pas une
question d'argent et caetera et dès
qu'on commence à parler de transaction
financée de partage la fameuse maison de
tourner la maison de mama coquette tout
de suite ça y est le ciel le ciel
s'embellit le ciel ya plus de nuages du
tout et ça y est on est on est copains
comme cochons c'est d'une hypocrisie
totale dont franchement du mal à passer
un groupe physique total et franchement
ça nul que ça vous plaît pas tout
simplement voilà oui oui il faut savoir
ce que vous voulez tant jean michel je
me souviens d'une discussion vous disiez
quand même ces scandales oeuvre mais qui
trouvent un accord fondé qui se mettent
autour d'une table il faudrait
maintenant ils commencent à se mettre
autour d'une table mais vous dites oh
mais qu'elle coûte promo quelle honte
moi j'avais jamais jamais du sommet je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait dit ça il avait
lu mon nom mais lui non mais bon c'est
sympa quand même
non mais vous devez vous juste un mot
pour dire quand même que toutes les
chaînes à fournes en parler aujourd'hui
alors qu'hier soir ici c'est bernard
montiel qui en exclusivité en
exclusivité à donner l'info de cette
affaire le rire ça ça a du bon de
croiser des mecs dans l'est dans les
point soleil
d'abord comme milliard je persiste et
signe je me dis qu'il johnny hallyday
n'a pas besoin de laëtitia pour faire la
promo alors si elle est là pour la
cotisation c'est très bien parce que moi
de mon regard que j'ai gelé les voir se
chamailler comme ça pour du pur du
pognon ça m'embête un peu parce que
c'est pas des smicards ils en ont déjà
du pognon donc s'il faut partager qu'ils
partagent mais faites-le discrètement ne
nous mettez pas ça comme ça l'a fait
comme à la fête comme gilles est pas
tout il faut voilà ils ont dû la vendre
sur le bon coin on attend l'argent mais
c'est tout et on attendra
on attendra temps qu'il faudra avoir la
garde à vue doit aussi comment une part
du gâteau quand même ce cfa tu sais pas
que symbolique est aussi certaine une
vingtaine de disques en cake toucherait
les droits d'auteurs et des 51 auquel il
a collaboré quand même effet après avoir
dû reste assez normal à collaborer de
monde ça non mais ça c'est normal un
resquilleur oui mais attention vous
n'avez rien dit